this is Mamie you might have seen her
football skills on social media
she's pretty much a showstopper wherever
she is
I was raised in a ghetto so we used to
play street football with the boys so
the fundamental of my skills started
back when I was seven eight years old
with them and back in 2018 I saw the
first girl doing a freestyle video on
Tick Tock and then because I've done so
much sweet football back in the time I
had like a good technique so I just
started trying to do the trick similar
to the other tick Tuckers and
instagramers and YouTubers and I just it
was easy for me to learn
as you can tell many people are in the
world cup spirit and will just come up
to Mimi and have friendly freestyle
battles like this
[Music]
I asked her to show me some tricks and
let's just say it's much harder than it
looks Mamie's videos have gotten lots of
attention on social media
it's not a secret that I'm a minority in
Denmark and growing up as a minority kid
it wasn't easy to be in the sports field
without having a role model looking like
me so I want to use my platform to
normalize the ideal picture of a woman
football player so it's not only the
blonde girl but also different kind of
girls
[Music]
so guys what do you think about her
skills she's better than
[Applause]